you know one of my biggest icks is when
there's a social media Trend among the
youths that I'm not part of
I've stumbled upon the latest craze
taking all over the tick tocks and the
interwebs and that would be women and
girls posting about their icks the
things that just disgust them that they
find repulsive and revolting about men
[Applause]
and I am going to bring to bear not only
my hip-hop pop culture knowledge my
fluency in the language and lingo of the
youths but also my many greater years of
experience in the relations between men
and women I'll be bringing to Bear My
Love Guru expertise just basically all
of my skills to ascertain the legitimacy
or illegitimacy of the various icks
ladies take it away what is the biggest
a guy when he's a birthday
he has a birth
if he gets cold it's like just just
bring a jacket bring a sweater I don't
know please don't be cold when he holds
my hands it's a little icky you don't
like the handhold okay no it's a bit
it's a big clammy the first one was a
little extreme when a guy has a birthday
that's an ick
since statistically every single man in
all of human history has had a birthday
but but then she clarifices when a man
celebrates his birthday I agree it's
kind of weak for a guy to care a lot
about his birthday even to remember his
birthday frankly I like having birthdays
I usually forget my birthday now because
I'm an old man and I have a wife and
children so I don't it's not about me
and then the getting cold totally true I
never want to hear a guy say oh I'm a
little chilly that's weak sauce man even
if you're the perfect temperature and
you got a woman there who is cold
because women are never satisfied with
the temperature inside or out I am
sweating more than I'm proud of then you
can offer them your jacket totally
chivalrous and then holding hands I
agree with that too it's got to be kind
of weird if if a woman holds my hand
hopefully my wife uh that's very nice I
like that perfectly happy to hold my
wife's hand but to reach out
for me is the man to reach out other
than in the most beautiful wistful rare
sort of circumstances I don't know that
seems kind of like a feminine Behavior
so I totally agree with all of those
icks this is
you're sure as if his stop score is
over 1 million okay when you're short as
again that's like a very standard
one for ladies right ladies want tall
guys and they'll pretend that it doesn't
matter but that lady's being honest
although frankly some of the most uh you
know accomplished men in history
Vladimir Putin Napoleon you know some of
these guys they're a little on the
shorter side anyway regardless uh okay
that one makes sense snap score what is
a snap score I don't know that reference
no I don't I do
I understood that reference Zoomer Jacob
has just gotten into my ear and said
it's it's just how many people you
message on Snapchat the people you're
snapping okay yeah that's bro that's
kind of icky let's just ask where 1.2
million
if it's a guy she belongs to the streets
if he was like actual flip-flops to the
beach it's disgusting fashionable boy
putting sheets on a bed and it like
falling off and they have to fix it egg
the littlest things give me the egg so
true yeah if a guy cares about the
neatness of his bed or anything like
that
that's a sign either that he was in the
military which I guess is good or if
he's a civilian who cares about the
sheets on his bed he's probably a little
bit light in the loafers that means
you're gay this thing about guys wearing
flip-flops totally agree even to the
beach loafers all day long and then I
guess the first gal would have to have
to specify what what she means by
s-h-i-t because if she means like five
foot flat then yeah you know that's
everybody's got problems and that's
going to be a tough problem for a guy
it's a touchy subject huh but I don't
know I mean you think Tom Cruise is
pretty petite guy a lot of basically
every actor and movie star type I don't
know but she would probably like those
guys but probably because they've got a
lot of money and fame and that taste
that appetite would overwhelm the
revulsion of the ick I'm sure there's a
spreadsheet somewhere and a calculation
to put it all together
agree with all of those I guess I'm on
the side of the girl I'm always on the
side of the girls huh these women's
demands don't seem unreasonable to me
and even if they're a little impolite
that they're made they're they're being
honest so I take that if a woman is not
going to deceive herself and society as
is often the female inclination if she's
going to be pretty blunt and reasonable
great I'm I'm with you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
that can't be real
[Music]
that's got to be a staged thing there's
no way that's real
[Music]
next one
what's your biggest say kind of guy like
when they
okay
that was so mean it's gonna say if
they're like really nice it's such an
egg be true
there we go man some honesty and you see
she didn't she knew I live in a
politically correct culture so I'm not
allowed to say that but I should be
polite they should be chivalrous they
should be gentlemen those are all good
things but that's different being like
oh nice I'm a nice little guy hey I'm
not like those mean guys I'm a nice guy
no woman wants that I just want to be
with a man who'll ignore me and take me
for granted and who's only pretending to
be interested this is not an original
observation I saw someone else make this
point the other day too modern culture
just gets things totally flipped so
modern culture pretends like we want
women to be girl bosses and that we want
men to be really nice weak beta
simps or whatever that's not true at all
we don't want either of those things we
want women to be women womanly and we
want men to be manly
and if you don't do that it's a big ick
[Music]
is that just a man
a tall man and a small man both jumping
on trampolines
is that an ick
what's icky about that I don't find that
icky at all
for one of my Pal's birthday his whole
family they just wanted to go to like a
circus Park and just jump around on
trampolines it's weird like I wouldn't
do it but in certain circumstances I
don't know that's fine it's got its
wholesome fun you like a guy right now
picture this him in an elevator like
just climb him using a grocery cart oh
you can't carry that you're not strong
enough okay I'm having to Google
something like why don't you just know
it
him trying to find a parking spot
get out of your car I'm trying to get a
drink at the bar but the bartender is
ignoring him and then you have to do it
then you feel like his mom
grow up him feeling cold
really him dropping something
try holding it tripping over something
this one makes me sad those breakups are
the hardest it's like I'm so sorry you
shouldn't have tripped now both of us
are suffering she's trying hard here and
is intentionally being somewhat
hyperbolic which is too bad it's almost
it's like 10 to 15 percent a little too
much not quite my Tempo it's all good no
worries but otherwise pretty funny and
spot on generally notice the second
expression of the cold ick you don't
want to hear that a man is chilly that's
weird you want a man to run hot you want
to be able to Latin blood you know Latin
blood pouring out making olive oil on
his skin the tripping the falling the
holding that's funny it's also weird
because the first picture is this guy
who looks like a giga Chad from the
1950s going to work in the elevator said
why would you take an elevator you could
just walk so that one aside all the rest
I kind of agree you know yeah you
shouldn't have to Google something I'm
with her on most of those eggs I just
got out of a 10-year relationship and
I'm gonna tell you the number one Nick
the ick to end all icks like a man does
this he is literally dead to me is the X
stringing a woman along for 10 years and
not marrying her I don't mean to be
harsh on this girl but that is insane
man that is
insane Behavior
what are you doing the man in his very
comportment and nature is icking but you
miss that for these more minor eggs okay
what's this particular Rick you don't
exist to me
and that is
being with me leaving me to be with
another woman and then coming back and
and wanting to be back with me after
comparing us that to me is like bottom
of the barrel Behavior
you who are you who are you king of the
castle to be walking around thinking
that he can go and be with other women
and compare and contrast and be like no
you're better the fact that you even had
to go is enough for me to say that you
are not worthy of me the fact you even
had to compare me to anyone else is
enough for me to say that I don't want
to be with you I'm not plan B
I'm playing A1 done but obviously not
because you let this guy string you
along for 10 years
and I don't know the nature of their
relationship but assuming that this is
more of a modern one and it went on for
10 years and you didn't get married
there was no rush then who does he think
he is I don't know he's the kind of guy
who can do that so I agree he is he is
teeming with ick I agree the ickiness is
producing a layer of degeneracy so thick
that it's hard to see the man underneath
I'm with you but who enabled the ick
lady come on women
stand up for yourself what's the matter
with you the little ick is and then he
came back and tried to win me no that's
not the ick the ick is everything else
you like the way it sounds sounds
[Music]
at least you didn't give her the ick
though very manly very manly folks
that's it what's my favorite ick
actually it's gonna be that first one
a man getting really into his birthday
you can find a case for all of these
like let's say he were you went on a
vacation to Antarctica and he had a
shiver you know I wouldn't say he's all
ick because he got a little chilly but a
grown man getting really excited about
his birthday
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my gosh